Continental Tire Coach's Corner princess
Tony Dungy Continental Tire proud to be
the exclusive tire the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive what you drive
how you drive they have a tire for you
for more information visit Continental
Tire dot-com
once again we spoke to Tony Dungy before
the show started so he could get on his
flight so we did not have the
information on Drew Brees Brees will
have surgery probably today and will be
out for the next six weeks Tony was
tweeting over the weekend on Sunday he
was just bothered by the stoppage in
play and the pass interference calls and
I started the conversation with Tony by
asking him how difficult was it to watch
those games yesterday you know what it
is tough Dan and also I think we're
still getting that kind of result of
lack of preseason you see some plays
especially at the end of game long
touchdown passes when the defense should
be protecting that fumbles bad snap
things like that miss kicks it's just I
think we're still kind of in that
preseason mode and we might not know
who's really really going to be good for
another couple of weeks
what frustrate what frustrated you the
most yesterday I think the pass
interference rules and I am just beside
myself with that I thought it was going
to be a real problem when we start
putting judgment into review and now
we're saying well this push off was
clear and obvious but this grab wasn't
clear and obvious we tell the Pittsburgh
Seattle game gets turned around on a
replayed review on past and advance an
offensive pass interference penalty took
away a touchdown for Minnesota they lose
by one score and I don't think coaches
really know now what the challenge what
what not because it's very inconsistent
yeah I'm trying to figure out you know
what is best for the NFL when I watch it
and when they started to add more
instead of subtracting and in its front
it's really frustrating to watch I
because anytime there's a long touchdown
I I just wait before I celebrate because
I think there's gonna be a flag on the
play
yeah I mean Stefon Diggs scores a
touchdown yesterday for Minnesota and
you're wondering what they're reviewing
and then they come up with with
something that's away from the play and
no one really saw and and it is it's
hard to figure out and now every pass
and when he really every passing
touchdown is gonna be subject to booking
all over the field to see if there was a
grab or push off I think it's hard and
then we really don't know what is clear
and obvious what's clear novice to me as
a defensive player might not be clear
and obvious to an offensive player and
that's what we're getting what would you
do if you were coaching now what would
it be your strategy it's really hard
because you get these big plays I'm
sitting there in the screening room and
Pete Carroll challenges this pass that I
say he's done he's gonna move the
timeout there's no way he should
challenge this and it ends up getting
the 40-yard gain out of it and the
change of the rule and so you don't know
then you take chances and you say okay
I'm gonna challenge this you saw on the
Thursday night game Ron Rivera made a
challenge it's clearly a penalty this
guy got bumped he got knocked off his
route but then they said well the ball
wasn't in the air so even though it's a
penalty we can't say
because it's not passing apparence I
don't know what coaches can do now I
really don't talking to Tony Dungy Hall
of Famer and of course football night
America analyst joining us Continental
Tire Coaches Corner
what is different about the Cowboys
offense this year than in previous
seasons I think they're back to where
they were Dax rookie year when he had
that breakout year they've got all the
pieces in place that year they had this
great offensive line racheal Elliott was
a rookie burst on the scene they had Dez
Bryant on the outside who was beating
one-on-one coverage and and then they
had Jason Witten kind of as that safety
valve
well Dez went downhill they lost Jason
Witten they had some injuries in the
offensive line but now it's all back so
he's just orchestrating this offense but
if you put your safety up in the line of
scrimmage to stop Elliott then you've
got all these one-on-ones on the outside
you've got receivers that can win he's
getting easy reads because the Safety's
ours back in the box and it's all in
place great protection good solid
running game and he's got receivers he
can see on one he's playing fantastic
football so is Lamar Jackson but I'm not
sure what is real and what's not because
they beat in Arizona and beat in Miami
but I I'm more curious about John
Harbaugh putting him in a position they
were down at the 5-yard line backed up
to the five and he dropped back to pass
I never thought I would see that from
Lamar Jackson but it seems like John
Harbaugh is allowing him to be a
quarterback he really is and the eighth
play of the game when they had to have a
place to ice the game they got an empty
no backs in the backfield we're going to
throw this ball he throws the faith to
Marquis Brown right on the money and
that told me what I needed to see you're
right John Harbaugh has confidence in
him now I'm really looking forward to
next week when Kansas City plays
Baltimore because Pat mahomes is doing
some things that we haven't seen - I
think you're going to see probably 80 85
points in that game okay and I think
just like the Rams
Chiefs game was last year yeah I
mr. know-it-all I said there'll be a
market correction on Patrick mahomes
he's not gonna have the season he had
last year sitting there looking
yesterday and I said Raiders has done a
pretty good job on it he's a little bit
off and he has 34 44 for 407 yards four
touchdowns and it wasn't even a great
day well he had a he had a better
quarter then I think all other
quarterbacks had games except for a more
Jackson they can explode and that's
really gonna be a fun game because I
think both defenses they're gonna have
their hands full
what about Antonio Brown working it felt
like they were limiting the playbook for
him but that's kind of scary
you got Josh Gordon and a B in there and
then you throw in Edelman you know now
all the sudden Patriots are a great
offense you saw to just film some
miscommunication Brady thought he was
going to be certain places a couple
times I think four out of eight targets
but at chemistry is only going to get
better and Brown is he's a rare talent
so I think they're going to do some
special things on offense now I still
wasn't happy with the signing because I
think it's sent a bad message to our
young people that you can act as crazy
as you want to as long as you have
talent and someone will take you but as
far as on the field they're going to be
tough to deal with more likely to happen
the Patriots go undefeated or the
Dolphins go winless I think they're both
probably not going to happen but the
Patriots they might have an easier time
during the 16 and o'the and then the
Dolphins have of winning one game the
way it looks now but I'm looking at this
Miami team I mean I feel bad for Brian
Flores I don't know if he signed up for
this I mean what would you do if if you
were coaching this team well they've got
a long term plan obviously and I think
you've got to ride it out and make sure
that you keep people on board the tough
thing is when you get rid of as many
good players as they have that makes it
difficult mentally but in the long run
and they're stockpiling some dresses
Cleveland
went through this and and we'll see if
Miami can come out the other side but
what Brian has to do is keep everybody
on board and that's going to be tough
how does Adam Vinatieri hit the wall at
this point of his career you know I
don't know if it's mental you know I
can't remember him missing five kicks in
a year let alone five kicks in two weeks
so I hope he comes back I hope he stays
with it I think he will bounce back so
still see the leg strength
I think the accuracy will come but gosh
I don't want Adam to go out like this
I hope this is not a retirement
day-to-day I hope it's you know just a
readjustment hey tone safe travels as
always and we hope to see you in the man
cave one of these come see you
definitely I'm mr. DP thank you tone
that's Tony Dungy football night in
America joining us Continental Tire
Coaches Corner for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]